foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome this is a session on how
economic headwinds fuel creativity and
I'm sure many of you in the audience no
matter where you work agency side client
side you run a business you're an
entrepreneur you're probably wondering
what's happening in the world we're
hearing about economic headwinds we're
hearing about
increases in inflation and then at the
same time we're also hearing about the
job market being stable and it's a
confusing picture but I'm joined by two
incredible guests who can actually help
us navigate some of those questions to
people that have driven both
entrepreneurship Innovation and
creativity from leading marketing
Communications all the way through to
funding businesses and big ideas as many
of you will be aware so please join me
in welcoming my two guests entrepreneur
and Mr Wonderful Kevin O'Leary
thank you
and the EVP of marketing and
Communications from MasterCard Rustin
Disturbed please welcome
all right okay so we're going to jump
straight in
um if you can see you can see on the
screen here there are as I said the it's
a confusing picture the story is mixed
for the last six months plus we're
hearing this is the world's worst
economy ever
um as I said in the US the job market
seems stable if you're in marketing
you're on the P L's at cost center
you're probably the first thing that's
being cut if you're in an agency your
clients are telling you how can you
optimize Performance Marketing has never
been more important data drives every
decision what are you going to do about
it so the most important thing to
remember is that Innovation is at the
heart of every crisis and what comes out
of a crisis and what comes through
Innovation are some of the best ideas
but let's kick it over to Kevin first to
tell us about what's happening in the
world and how you see this and how would
you advise everyone in the room on how
to think about this economic Whirlwind
that we're in well I agree with the idea
that perplexing because each recession
and I've lived through and I've seen
this movie many times before has its own
personality this one's unique it's very
hard to contemplate a recession at full
employment yet that's what we have and
in my portfolio of companies private all
of them
um about 56 of them they're across all
11 sectors of the s p and almost every
geography in the U.S we see the tear
sheets for revenue and cash flow on a
very orderly basis often once a week we
were here's the challenge for any small
business right now
so full employment
we haven't seen a Slowdown in consumer
demand I don't care what it is is it
insecticide is it grading cards is it
commercial Kitchens cupcakes gym
equipment wireless charger we have all
that stuff we haven't seen a Slowdown
yet and at the same time you're watching
all this Doom and Gloom and I see it too
and so do the CEOs of these companies
and their decision the hard part of all
this is what to do about inventory going
into holiday and q1 do you pull back
because you think this recession is
going to hit us in Q4 which we're
basically in right now and holidays
coming up in a few weeks extended
holiday this year by over three days
which if you're doing 200 million 150
million sales a lot of inventory and so
you're trying to gauge the pessimism out
there as the stock market tries to
forecast the future in 2023 Meanwhile
your sales are humming so do you want to
leave anything on the table and more of
a perplexing situation coming out of the
pandemic is most of these companies have
gone past 50 percent direct to Consumer
models big succulent margins direct to
Consumer bypassing retail advertising
digitally acquiring customers
economically they know their CAC they
know their subscription Services they
know the attrition rates they're making
money and if they sell product online
that they don't have to ship well you
should burn in hell in perpetuity for
that and so you know that's basically
the challenge this that most small
businesses have there is no evidence of
a recession yet yet clearly the market
is telling you it's coming you just
don't know when the last speculation
I'll make the reason this is happening
is we printed 6.7 trillion dollars
basically for free in 30 months and then
we say oh there's inflation well no [ __ ]
there's inflation because extra cash
chasing fewer Goods creates higher
prices which is what's happened but all
that cash is still sloshing around which
is why the consumer is not dead yet
that's my two cents on it awesome well
rustam you're looking at consumer spend
data every day this guy should know yeah
tell us what you're saying
look we we look at as a payments company
this is our lifeblood so we look at
consumer spend data very closely for the
month of September we're still seeing
data look very strong for consumers and
consumer spend retail data online and
traditional it's not just strong
relative to this year it's strong
relative to two years ago pre-pandemic
so there's a lot of pent-up demand that
is bursting through into retail spend
the question is how long that pent-up
demand lasts now one of the things we
hypothesize is that some of that is just
because household savings was so high
during the pandemic and there's that
sort of burst to get out to spend to
consume again and as Kevin said there's
all this extra money floating around in
the economy but what we've got to be
sort of a little bit conscious of is
that that phenomenon may be coming to an
end where especially at the lower end of
the spectrum that incremental household
cash that existed might start drying up
and as we start going into the holidays
and into next year with lending also
tightening and no physical help coming
from the FED for for borrowers into next
year you might see some of this demand
contract and level of Priceless prices
prices and cool things down a little bit
so there is some sort of uh belief that
as we go into the fourth quarter and
early next year we might get a truer
picture than what we're seeing today
it's really interesting um we were just
talking in the back about what we're
seeing at meta and for small businesses
in particular we just released our 10th
state of Small Business Report globally
uh similar Trends you know businesses
are not reopening at the rate that we
would have expected about 19 still
remain closed in the United States and
20 globally but what we are seeing in
terms of positive Trends are hiring 74
of businesses told us that they are
they've hired a lot more in the last six
months than ever before and also the use
of digital tools you know that continues
to increase and I was just saying to
Kevin in the back that the trend we're
seeing is women-owned businesses are
actually leading the way in terms of
their sales
through digital versus men which you
know big it up for the women in the room
I think that's a really fantastic way to
lead but you know if you're walking into
the c-suite and you're a marketer or a
small business and you're looking for
investment what are you saying to CEOs
and CFOs to convince them that this is a
good place to spend money
well there has been a change in investor
sentiment regarding investing in small
business and here's what it is because
of what occurred during the pandemic
this remarkable digital pivot
I call it you know America 2.0 where
companies that pre-pandemic if you look
at the pie chart of Revenue it would
have been 50 through retail 40 through
Amazon just another retailer except you
don't get the data from them 10 your own
website that's completely changed the
successful companies that went through
the pandemic even Amazon went to
essential Goods only if you remember in
February March April and May of 2020 so
those companies had to build out their
own platforms and start acquiring
customers so if you look for an a round
or B round or C round in a small
business now and you go to the investor
community and say look I'm looking for
money the first question every investors
analyst asks you and we're no different
do you know your CAC your customer
acquisition costs do you know your
attrition rate of customers do you know
the lifetime value of that customer and
are you now past 50 direct to Consumer
because when you get past 50 direct to
Consumer you get something more valuable
than anything you get data your own data
size preference flavor frequency of
purchase price Point regional
disparities on flavors and all kinds of
sizes and differences in people's
preference just like the wine business
for example what people drink in Florida
is completely different than what they
drink in Ohio and if you're selling
direct which you can to 42 States now
you have that data and that data is
priceless it's the new oil data is the
new oil so if your company can't analyze
data you're not collecting data you
don't even understand what I'm talking
about no chance in hell you're getting
an investment you're just going to go
out of business because your competitors
are so much better than you that's
what's different in the last two years
data companies that know how to mine
data and understand it because that's
the first thing we ask if you understand
your CAC I can pour four five six
million dollars onto it and grow the
business dramatically because we already
know I'm just pouring gasoline on the
fire if you don't know we don't even
read the deck
that's so interesting it's about knowing
your consumer tell us more you're in a
marketing position and data obviously is
critical to how you think about it I
mean just building on the theme cabin uh
LED off with is that a small business
today has to be a digital business there
is no option and we see that in our data
large digital businesses grow about
three times as fast as small businesses
online simply because they're better set
up to do so and this is a societal
problem this is not just a small
business problem we cannot have small
businesses fail because they're not
digital businesses so in many cases it
is that education it is those tools it
is empowerment it is mentorship it is
enabling them to mine data the way
Kevin's talking about so they have a
legitimate competitive proposition in
the digital space now what we also see
is that when you are a service business
your digital proposition is a little
stronger as a small business than a
large business so for example tax
accounting or any small business that
that affords or offers a service tends
to do larger than a commoditized large
business in the online space so while
data is important taking that data and
applying a service proposition around it
is also incredibly important yeah I
actually think that's super interesting
you know we you think about the
businesses that have built their
business on Facebook or Instagram when
you think about Instagram you often sort
of quickly go to retail and fashion and
cosmetics and you know things that you
like to see in your feed but it's
actually the service Industries the
accountants the hairstyles the legal
advisors that are actually doing
phenomenally well by creating community
and talking directly to their customers
through our platforms
so let's talk a little bit about risk
um you know again how would you advise
people in this room to think about in
this world where everybody's feeling a
little bit risk-averse and buttoning
down the hatches what would you say is a
reasonable risk to take we'll start with
you from a marketing perspective would
be great to hear sure you know I always
cringe a little bit when we die
marketing with budgets I always get that
Converse that that question how do you
go and talk to your CFO about money I
don't want to talk to my CFO about money
I want to talk to him about opportunity
marketing is a competitive Advantage for
a business and more important than money
is ingenuity and when the money tightens
the Ingenuity has to grow even more so
what I'm looking for from my teams for
the next year is not to worry all day
and night about what the budget is but
it's what are you going to do with the
money you have how are you going to make
it work harder because I think that's
where the real magic happens not just in
the budget on its own so when it comes
to risk taking there are many things we
will do differently next year than this
year if the if the ability to spend
contracts which we expect it might then
we'll do more targeted work we'll get
better on segmentation we'll talk uh
less to fewer people but more
effectively we'll find loyalty and
retention as a bigger objective than
acquisition so there's a lot you can do
to manage these moments but you've got
to show Ingenuity and not just depend on
a budget and check I love that that's
really helpful what do you think about
that Kevin and you know any advice well
I take I take a slightly different
approach because if I look at a company
and they're spending 12 to 18 percent of
their income statement on
marketing essentially I want to know
what the return of that is and so to me
that is measured by customer acquisition
costs because I don't care who you are
what you sell
it's as you said with some that it's
about digital I mean it
every business is successful even Nike a
giant Behemoth during the pandemic they
claimed it was going to take them six
years to get the fifty percent direct
consumer in all geographies they did it
in five months and as a result survived
the pandemic at much higher margins and
free cash flow because the only cost you
have if your director consumer is
manufacturing Logistics of shipping and
customer acquisition costs that's it now
if you have that situation you're
bypassing the traditional distribution
saving 40 percent and that goes right
back into the business so for me it's if
you're spending money on marketing are
you constantly experimenting with new
ideas so I all I've always said to my
companies I want a third of marketing to
be experimental every quarter because if
you're just sitting on your laurels
doing the same old crap you're missing
out and your competitors are going to do
something else so start experimenting
because the value of something that
works that you find through just
creative chaos is extremely higher than
what you've already even doing because
you start losing yields right away
whatever your strategy is and let's say
you're getting a two percent response on
it
watch six months from now it'll be 1.7
or 1.5 what's the next thing what's the
next idea what's the next drop what's
new because it's so noisy out there as
you all know you've got to keep creating
and everybody has the tools to do that
obviously yields are way down from two
years ago because of what Apple did on
privacy but that doesn't mean you can't
fix it by Smashing data together if
you're using meta you can buy other
services the target your customers in
various geographies and we do that a lot
and I'm shamelessly promoting them but
I'm using C squared social in a lot of
my companies now because they're small
they're entrepreneurs and I'm a paid
spokesperson that's true but it's
because I eat my own cooking I spend
money on them to get my yields up on
meta and I do let's say you've lost 28
of your yield because of Apple which is
approximately what you lost you can get
back half of that when you start
smashing data from other sources
including yours I mean there's data out
there the credit card companies and
banks have that help you do this now if
you don't know what I'm talking talking
about you're screwed anyways so this is
a standard procedure right now in terms
of putting together good campaigns
I love that well I really agree with the
experimenting
um points you're making you know we we
have a pop-up around the corner here for
meta you should go and check it out but
we're showcasing sunglasses company
called Desi which is a founder and
Creator owned
um they have beautiful products the
whole line has been built through
Instagram and Facebook and they sold
three thousand pairs of sunglasses in 48
hours through a campaign that they um
you know they tried through different
formats on reels and Instagram stories
and so on so I totally agree with the
sentiment you've got to keep
experimenting to be one step ahead and
it's a little bit about the what we talk
about with our new company name meta and
the metaverse you know that is a longer
Road out but there are certainly ways
that Brands and businesses can start to
experiment with ar filters and using 3D
ads and starting to understand how
consumers of the future are going to
connect with brands in these new
platforms and areas so I'm going to put
up a slide now and I'm going to have
some audience participation so what you
can see here is about 14 different
companies and
um the question for all of you is that
you know it's hard to imagine getting
back to growth in a time like this you
know in a time of Economic downturn and
so the question for everyone is how many
of these companies do you think started
in the recession so I'll do a show of
hands
five about five of them start in a
recession
eight
this is a tough crowd 10 is 14 10 okay
14.
okay there's only 14 on the slide one
all right well the answer is we can do
the reveal all of them and so the point
here is you know restaurant said it
really well continue to innovate
continue to be
um you know experimental marketing
should be ingenious and you should be
taking these ideas through to the
c-suite as much as you can so if we go
to our next question
um you know we talked a little bit about
um creativity and how can you you know
we talk about performance and CAC and
data but how can Brands continue to be
creative in this environment and I'll
ask you Russian when you think about Big
Ideas and everything that MasterCard has
stood for over the years what's the
right balance there between brand versus
performance sure look as a payments
company our ambition or goal is to make
payments as safe as possible and as
frictionless as possible
and we're constantly innovating to do
that it starts with the consumer and how
do we make that consumer experience at
the point of payment just that much
better and no one wakes up in the
morning thinking gee how am I going to
pay today no what you want to do is
enjoy your life you want to book that
vacation you want to buy a new pair of
clothes you want to buy a car you want
to make the payment moment as
fictionless as possible so everything we
do with Innovation is to try and make
that happen now as devices exponentially
become connected devices the the
opportunity to build payments mechanisms
into these devices just grows so I see
Kevin wearing a watch or a ring that if
it's a connected device can become a
payments device you can simply embed the
Payments Technology in there and you can
tap it on on a NFC code and you can go
from there so that makes the the payment
moment frictionless now what we saw
during covid is that a couple of things
we were trying like getting contactless
cards more prevalent getting e-commerce
with card on file more prevalent I mean
just the best first that we got out of
covet because that became such an
important consumer moment and such an
important hygiene moment for consumers
not to have to touch devices Etc and
unfamiliar places that our innovation of
the last 10 years just blossomed in that
environment so we're already starting to
think about how do we continue to make
payments frictionless so no matter what
the environment the consumer will
gravitate towards safer easier faster
ways to pay
that's so interesting what are you
seeing on the payment side of some of
the businesses that you've supported on
I am using a use case I teach a lot of
graduating cohorts of Engineers I always
go to the graduating cohort because a
third of the class is very
entrepreneurial and they do deals and I
get to see them before the VCS do them
so I'm doing this on a selfish basis but
it really works there's a use case I
want to show you and this is a shout out
for rustam
um here's a payment systems are so
brutally competitive in fintech it's
impossible let's take a use case of a
credit card the chance that you could
launch a credit card in this market in
my mind as an investor zero probability
of success because you'll never acquire
customers here's one built this is a
MasterCard what this guy did first time
I ever invested I own a piece of this
company he came to me and said I'm going
to use Community I'm going to go to
Every renter in America and let them pay
their rent on a credit card how crazy is
that idea because I said it'll never
happen you can't shave three percent out
of out of a landlord he said no the
landlords pay nothing we're going to
make this work for the landlords and
make our money on all the other things
people do with this card
very had a plan to go to a community and
use social media say you pay rent you
want to increase your credit score you
was built this thing is the fastest
growing card in America his cack is low
because if you rent you want this I knew
it was going to work when my daughter
and son called me and said there's a
waiting list you got to call the guy up
you're an owner I need the card they
were screaming to get their rent paid on
it because it's two three four thousand
a month that they're getting credit for
brilliant brilliant idea that's using
Community that's using social media
that's a payment system but the key
there is he figured out CAC everybody
else is trying to launch credit cards
goes to zero almost immediately they
can't compete with MasterCard American
Express Visa it's impossible to gain
share against those guys unless you're
in bed with them and you have a
different approach which is what built
did that's Innovation that's
entrepreneurship and boy does that guy
spend on social media he's insane
because he knows his CAC he can pour
gasoline on it when I invested in it it
was a 5 million valuation we just did
another round of 1.5 billion that was 18
months ago
that's what I'm talking about here
that's innovation in payments does
everyone know Kevin's whole wallet is
here so if you've got an idea I just
noticed that to meet us in the green
room let's talk a little bit about
community and then I'll wrap it up but
um again Moscow does some tremendous uh
work across the community and I love
hearing these stories where business
ideas are sort of borne out of what the
like we're a brander company answers
back tell us more about MasterCard and
what you're doing there yeah I'll give
you a small example uh you know one of
the things that so if this is the 25th
anniversary of our Priceless campaign 25
years ago we came up with this idea that
there are some things in life money
can't buy for everything else as
MasterCard and it's kind of been the the
philosophy on which the company has been
built over the last 25 years and we saw
a community idea that came from actually
one of our employees that has been a
huge success it's called the true name
card it's a card that allows you to put
your chosen name on the card now if you
are a person who is who is going through
a transgender transition and are
transgender the worst thing possible is
to put your credit card down at a shop
or a restaurant and have the stigma of
someone looking at the name and
questioning whether that's really you
now the reality is we don't need the
name to process a transaction we just
need the 16-digit code and the and and
the security code we don't need the name
so why is the name so important for the
card at a point of payment so we give
people the option to put whatever the
whatever name they want whether it's
because they're going through a gender
transition or whether it's because they
want to use uh a maiden name or a
professional name or any name that they
might want and this is just opened up
such a host of possibilities for people
that were otherwise stigmatized by a
product feature that wasn't needed
so it's not Technology Innovation but it
is tactile simple life Innovation that
has just made life that much better for
a consumer
no example similar to what you know we
when we think about avatars and you know
we've been talking a lot about d2c but
think about D to a which is going to be
direct to Avatar and what identities
people can create in the future world
where you can be whoever you want to be
and move across different platforms and
express yourself in ways that matter
most to you in that environment and I
just think this is we're just at the
start of this as marketers who really
have to understand what the future of
segmentation looks like in a world where
you know you describe that we can be
whoever we want to be and I'm super
excited to to see where we go with that
if you like that video will you see my
next one don't forget to click right
over here and subscribe